we come now to the main course and it
couldn't be served more attractively
than by a young star who is the West
Coast distributor of charm
miss Audrey Hepburn
that lovely introduction bub
I agree how would you like to make a
picture with me I've had an offer to
remake some of the old William Powell
Myrna Loy pictures I think you'd be
great but I could never be as good as
bill power
I'm honored to present the award for the
best motion picture of the year the
Academy members have nominated the Alamo
BACtrack United Artists John Wayne
producer the apartments the nearish
company United Artists Billy Wilder
producer Alma gantry Burt Lancaster
Richard Brooks United Artists Vernon
Smith producer Sons and Lovers Company
of artists 20th Century Fox Gerry world
producer the sundowners Warner Brothers
Fred cinnamon producer
I I don't know what to say this award of
course belongs to the entire team the
technician center the actors the extras
the wonderful people in the back locked
into the wonderful mirrors in the front
office but I think it would be only
proper to to cut it right in half and to
give it to the two most valuable players
mr. Jack Lemmon and miss Shirley
MacLaine